people would rather stay poor than do
something entrepreneurial and it's crazy
to me but there are three reasons why
this is the first reason is because they
have a fear of judgment they're afraid
that people are going to laugh at them
call them names or call them a scammer
the second reason is fear of rejection
so if people don't want what they're
selling they feel like they're not good
enough and they're just being rejected
by everyone the third reason and this is
the most powerful one in my opinion is
the fear of failure so this is losing
money it just not working out and the
whole thing just crumbles If you
eliminate all three of these things in
your mind when you start your chances of
succeeding in business and in life in
general will go through the roof